ChatGPT
is going to take your job.
Not really.
But we are seeing some very interesting things
because of ChatGPT.
It's changing the way a lot of people
work. It's It's able to augment and enrich
your own capabilities with that with the collective
experience of the Internet. The model can be
trained with smaller subsections of data to help
make using existing applications easier.
And we're going to see an example of
that today.
Let's talk about Kubescape.
Fantastic product that helps improve your security posture
for all of your Kubernetes clusters.
That is if you stick to the frameworks
provided by Kubescape and
which to be fair is pretty comprehensive.
However,
some organizations may wish to write their own
controls
for their own frameworks.
And writing your own controls has been a
little bit tedious today. Not because of Kubescape,
but because of the language they're written in.
Controls
are written in Regal. Watch Regal.
Regal is a language that is part of
open policy agent.
And it's not like other programming languages that
you may be familiar with. A lot of
people struggle with its syntax mostly around comprehension.
It can sometimes be hard
to read a Regal program and actually know
what's going on because at times it feels
like there's bits of magic especially
around iterators
on lists.
So this is prime real estate for chat
to come in and make your life easier.
And fortunately for us, the team at Armo
have done all the heavy lifting.
Thank you.
So we're gonna use Armo platform today
where they have a UI for building
custom
controls. Now as you'll see in our website,
if you want to go and find out
more, please feel free. But I am already
logged in
to ARMOR
where if you click on your face and
settings
followed by controls,
you can click create custom control where you
provide a name,
severity,
a wish or what you want the control
to do
with the ability to provide a description,
an example object and a remediation path if
you wish. However,
you don't need to. You can let ChatGPD
work it out for you. So in this
short video, we're gonna take a look at
some prompts and some custom controls generating Regal
policies for us and making our lives easier.
Let's check it out. So let's start with
a nice easy one just to warm ChatGPT
up. I'm going to call this control
no
latest
tag. I'm going to paste in a prompt
that says ensure deployments
never use the latest tag. Not going to
provide any examples, descriptions, or remediation.
I'm just going to let ARMOR platform and
chat GPD
work it out. Now we have a response.
The description is to prevent the use of
the latest tag in Kubernetes workloads,
which makes perfect sense to me. The remediation
path as generated by a ChatGPD
is to update the image tag to a
specific version. Again,
pretty spot on.
Over on the right hand side,
we have the Ragel rule or the Ragel
policy.
Because you hear that it looks at all
resources.
It does this by expanding the input
as a list.
The underscore means get them all. From here,
it has a list of the different workload
types available in Kubernetes. Deployment,
replica set, daemon set, stateful set, and jobs.
From there, it checks the workload as of
one of these kinds, pulls out the image
of the first container,
runs a comparison check to see if it
contains a string colon latest.
And if so, we get an error message.
From here, you can click download your control.
Once that's downloaded, you can pop it open
and take a look if you wish. You'll
see your control name and ID,
the built in Regal,
and the resources to apply the policy. On
the command line, you can run Kubescape scan
control
no latest tag,
where this is the name or ID that
you put into the control name form or
you can find in the JSON as we've
seen a moment ago. Next, we provide use
from and provide the file name to where
you downloaded your policy. The last parameter is
the resource or directory of resources that you
wish to scan.
And now we have a failed resource on
our no latest tag control, one failed resource
against two scanned. So let's pop open
our deployment dot YAML.
And as we can see here, the first
container in our deployment is NGINX with a
latest tag that we do not want. So
let's run our scan one more time.
Past.
Perfect.
Better security posture already
with a little help from the AI. But
we made that a little bit easy for
ChatGPT
and ARMOR platform.
So let's kick it up a notch. Let's
make this a little bit more challenging for
ChatGPT.
Let's say that we want a secure container.
And actually what we mean by secure is
that we don't want to allow any workload
in our cluster to add the capability
cap sysadmin.
So let's just type that up exactly as
I said it.
Do not allow
any workloads
to add
the cap
admin
capability
and click generate.
Okay. We have our secure control.
Deny CAPSYS admin capability to workloads with the
remediation path that basically says, hey, don't add
this capability. And on the right hand side,
we have some Rego.
So let's download this.
But before we run it locally on a
CLI, I want to show you a cool
little trick. First, open a new tab in
your browser
and search for the Rego playground
and click go.
This is an interactive playground that allows you
to test your Ragel policies.
And I'm going to paste in the Ragel
that we copied from the ARMOR platform and
you can click format.
From here, you can copy your example workload.
As we can see here, I have a
deployment but a stored as YAML.
Convert it to JSON,
create a list and paste it in. Again,
click format to tidy it up. Now we
have an interactive test bed that allows us
to evaluate
our Regal policies.
So let's add the capability
that we don't want to our workload,
like so.
And if we click evaluate,
we don't get a deny in our output,
something is not quite right. So the best
way to debug this in a Regal playground
is
to turn on the options for coverage.
Now when we click evaluate, we will see
a line by line breakthrough of any evaluation
that was true or false.
And as we can see here, it never
reaches line eight where it checks with the
capability capsid admin being added. And the reason
is the path
for the container spec
or properties
on our deployment is incorrect. Now I've noticed
this a few times with the chat GPT
integration is that it's not always good at
getting spec templates, spec containers versus resource spec
containers.
So you may have to tweak this depending
on the policy you get back from the
integration. To fix this, I can do spec
template
spec
like so. Now when we click evaluate, we
get our error message
that we can know that we shouldn't be
adding Capsys admin to our pod.
So let's remove it
and add cap net
raw
and evaluate.
Now our policy is successful.
Now if you're wondering how to tweak this
within the JSON that you've downloaded from the
ARMOR platform,
you can come here, copy your secure policy
like so. Pop it open in Versus code
and save it to force it to format.
Your rule is where the Rago lives here.
We can scroll along and modify
Like so. So it can be a little
bit finicky, but it's not that hard to
fix. Plus, we just described
a policy
to block capsid admin being added as a
capability to any pod without having to understand
too much about the RADO language. That is
pretty cool. So go check out ARMOR platform.
Use the custom controls and AI to help
you generate all the Regal that you need
for your cluster. Is it perfect?
No. But software rarely is. But I can
tell you that the team at Armo are
improving this integration every single day. But what
doesn't work today when you're watching this video
may very well work tomorrow. I'm gonna be
keeping a close eye on this integration because
it personally solves a lot of the challenges
that I have right in Regal. And sometimes
all you need is a little kick start
to get you going. So go check it
out. Have some fun and let me know
how you get on in the comments. Have
a great day.